ritu sahar thought her flat was an
investment
but with grenfell style cladding wrapped
around the building
her life is consumed by fear if the
cladding started to burn
i would actually be having to run
through walls of fire in order to get to
the fire escape
owners in this block have had to install
new safety measures
including fire marshals to watch the
building 24 7.
we have paid more than half a million
pounds for the fire marshals ourselves
owners could also foot the bill of
replacing all of the building's cladding
it's no surprise then that not a single
flat in this block
has sold for three years mortgage
providers will only lend money towards
the purchase of a property
that has met certain safety standards
one of the common questionnaires that
forms part of this assessment
is the ews one form and there are
approved inspectors
who can sign off on these forms now the
problem is
since the grenfell tower fire three
years ago there's been a sudden demand
for these inspectors
and there just aren't enough of them
around so leaseholders are being warned
they could face
lengthy delays with some claiming the
waiting list
is as long as 10 years lenders do have
duties of care they
should not be lending money to people to
enable them to live in properties
there are actually a fire risk and
therefore getting
the ews one form or some kind of fire
safety report
is key to the whole transaction for the
lender the ministry of housing
communities and local government says it
doesn't support the blanket use of ews
one forms
and encourages lenders to accept
equivalent evidence
but nikki cooper says her housing
association peabody
claimed they couldn't help when she
tried we've been told they
they don't want to do the form despite
us being able to find engineers that
would do it in a matter of weeks
they don't want to pay for that because
they don't want it to basically open a
can of worms for them
peabody told us sadly there is no quick
solution
it's an issue affecting hundreds of
thousands of people up and down the
country
and is being driven by mortgage lenders
and valuers
wanting evidence that is complex and
difficult to obtain
nikki is among hundreds of thousands of
so-called mortgage prisoners
who say they're unable to get the right
certification to sell
and unable to afford to make their homes
fire safe
zarya chowdhury sky news